Problem 5.
Use the expression below
to answer the
question that follows.
OK, there's my expression,
and here's the
question that follows.
Which of the following is the
best estimate of the value of
the expression above?
So when they want best estimate,
it's really just
saying, look, you don't have
to do all of the math.
Just kind of round out
everything and try to figure
out what this is saying.
So if I wanted to round this
out at the 32,629, I'd say
that's approximately equal to
30,000 times-- instead of 484,
I'm going to say that's roughly
equal to 500, and then
divide that by 306,751.
I'm going to say that's roughly
equal to 300,000.
So the first thing I want to do,
maybe I'll divide the top
and the bottom by 3, so this
30,000 will become-- let me do
it in darker color-- will
become 10,000, and this
300,000 will become 100,000.
And then I can start
canceling out 0's.
If I divide the top and the
bottom by 10,000, I could
essentially get rid of four 0's
on the top and the bottom.
So then, I'd just, 10,000
divided by 10,000
will just become 1.
100,000 divided by 10,000
is just 10.
That just becomes 10.
And then we're left with
500 divided by 10.
We can just cancel out
some more 0's.
Divide the top and the bottom
by 10, you get a 1 in the
bottom and you get
a 50 on top.
So you could say this is roughly
equal to 50, and lucky
for us, that's actually
one of the choices.
Problem 6.
Use the diagram below
to answer the
question that follows.
The measurements in the diagram
above are shown
rounded to the nearest
whole number.
Which of the following is a
possible value of A, the area
of the rectangle?
So what they're saying is that
these numbers, these aren't
the actual values if we were to
be precise about it, they
just rounded them to the
nearest whole number.
When you just multiply these two
things to figure out the
area, you get an area of 8
inches, or 8 square inches.
But when you look at the
choices, I don't see an 8
square inches.
It seems like it's either
going to be B or C.
And if you just look at these
two numbers, which one's
closer-- see, 8 to 5.5, so
8 minus 5.5, that's what?
8 minus 5 is 3 inches, so this
is 2 and 1/2 inches.
So we're 2 and 1/2 inches from
this one, and we are 3 and 1/2
inches from this one.
So if I was stuck for time,
I would go with this one.
But just to verify that this
definitely could be an answer,
if these are rounded to the
nearest whole number, then
this one could be as low
as 1.5 inches, right?
If this dimension is actually
1.5 inches when they rounded
it, they would have made it 2.
It couldn't have been 1.49,
because then they would have
rounded it down.
Similarly, this could have
been as low as 3.5.
When they round it, they would
have rounded it to 4.
It couldn't have been 3.49,
because then they would have
rounded it down to 3.
So if this dimension was 3.5,
and this dimension was 1.5,
what would the area have been?
So 3.5 times 1.5.
Let's see, 5 times 5 is 25.
3 times 5 is 15, plus 2 is 17.
Put a 0 down.
1 times 5 is 5.
1 times 3 is 3.
5, 7 plus 5 is 12.
And then you have 1 plus
1, plus 3 is 5.
You have two numbers behind
the decimal point, 5.25.
So the minimum possible area
for this rectangle is 5.25.
That's the minimum.
So 5.5 is definitely
a valid answer.
So I'm going to stick
with my answer, B.
Next problem.
All right.
Use the table below to answer
the questions-- the question--
that follows.
OK, they have a store, different
stores, discount for
manufacturer's recommended
price.
OK, there we go.
So they're all discounting
games.
Samantha wants to buy two
computer games, each of which
has a manufacturer's recommended
price of $20.
She checks four different stores
and finds the prices of
the games discounted as shown
in the table above.
At which store will Samantha be
able to buy the games for
the least amount of money?
That makes sense.
You want to find the
cheapest place.
So this is $4 off the
price of each game.
Remember, she's buying two.
The manufactured price is $20.
So she's going to pay $4 off of
$20 for each game, so she's
going to pay $16 plus $16,
which is equal to $32.
That's at store number one.
30% discount on each game.
So 30% discount, so $20 times
30% discount is 0.3.
So you can imagine 3 times 20
is 60, and then you put the
decimal sign.
It's going to be a $6 discount
on each game for this one.
So $6 discount.
Remember 30% of $20 is $6, so
$6 discount will be $14,
right? $20 minus $6 per
game that she buys.
So she's going to spend $28
at store number two.
Switch colors.
1/3 off the price of
the two games.
Well, you know, you could
immediately say that 1/3 is
33%, so that's a bigger discount
than this one.
You could do the math.
You'll figure out, you know,
instead of this being $6,
it'll be $6.66, and it's going
to be $13 and something
something, plus $13, and
something something.
You're going to get something,
you know, $27 and some change.
But you know that this is a
better deal than this one,
because this is the same thing
as 33% off, which is clearly
better than 30% off.
And then this fourth one-- buy
one game, and get the second
at 1/2 price.
So here, she's going to spend
$20 on the first game, and
then the second one is going
to be 1/2 price.
So she's going to spend
a total of $30.
So the best deal is store number
three, where it's going
to be $27 something.
Right?
I mean, store number two is
definitely better than store
number four, which is definitely
better than store
number one.
And then store number three is
definitely better than store
number two.
It's a 33% discount.
So I'm going to go with
store number three.
Next problem.
Go to the next problem.
8.
Use the procedure below
to answer the
question that follows.
OK, n is equal to 0.632, OK.
100n is equal to 63, just
multiply it by 100.
OK, they're trying to eliminate
the repeating decimals.
I get it.
The procedure above shows how to
convert a repeating decimal
to a fraction.
All right.
If 0.12561256 is a decimal with
four repeating digits,
which of the following
represents this
decimal as a fraction?
So what you do, we'll just do
what the procedure we did
before, and this might bring you
back memories from algebra
class, or pre-algebra
class, you get
when you first started.
You say n.
Or we can just do exactly what
they did there, is equal to
0.12561256, and then we
can multiply that.
And you can even
pattern match.
Here, you had two digits
repeating, they
multiplied it by 100.
And 100 has two 0's.
Here we have four digits
repeating, so we're going to
multiply it by something
with four 0's.
So we'll have 1, 1, 2, 3, 4.
There's our four 0's.
So that's 10,000n is going
to be equal to what?
What's 0.1 of 10,000?
It's 1,000.
What's 0.02 of 10,000?
I think you get the idea.
It is 2,000.
Sorry, it's 200.
So you get 1,256.12561256.
It just keeps repeating,
on and on and on.
You get the idea.
We just multiplied this by
10,000 because that allowed us
to bring one whole repetition
to the left of the decimal.
You could verify that.
Actually, let's multiply it out,
just to verify that this
actually works.
If I multiply 12561256 times
10,000, what you could do is,
you could just multiply
it by 1.
So you get 12561256, add
four 0's, 1, 2, 3, 4.
And then count how many decimal
points you have, 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
And we verify that it works.
Now, of course, I didn't
multiply the
entire repeating part.
If it just kept repeating, then
we'd have a 1256 and it'd
keep repeating, so
on and so forth.
But you saw it worked in the
pattern, and it works here.
So once we get that, we just
essentially want to subtract
this guy from this guy.
So we say minus n, or you could
say this is equal to
minus 0.12561256, and we are
left with-- on this side,
what's 10,000 minus 1?
Well, that's 9,999 is equal
to-- well, when you do the
subtraction, this and this part
are going to cancel out.
The decimal parts cancel
out, and you're
just left with 1,256.
So 9,999n-- remember, there's
a coefficient there, I don't
want to lose that--
is equal to 1,256.
Or if we divide both sides by
9,999, you get-- so n is equal
to 1,256 divided by 9,999.
And that is one of
our choices.
1,256 divided by 9,999.